DAN DAY: Good afternoon everyone and welcome to
Princeton University. My name is Dan day
I'm the assistant vice president for
communications here at the University
and we welcome you to today's
celebration of a Nobel Prize in Physics
by Professor Duncan Haldane, and we are
delighted to have you here with us today
and also delighted to have those of you
watching our live stream through the
University website and I believe also on
Facebook. Before we begin our program I'd
like to give a few instructions on how
this news conference and celebration will
work. We'll start with remarks by the
president of Princeton University,
Chris Eisgruber, and the chair of the
physics department, Lyman Page. After
that, Professor Haldane
will speak. When he concludes we will
open the floor to questions from the
news media. I will call upon each member
of the media and we'll have a mic
runner bring a microphone to the
reporter so everyone can hear.
We're also receiving questions remotely
from the media from those who cannot be
here and I may relay a few of those
questions to the professor. Beyond the media
we have a good number of faculty
students and staff here in the
auditorium, and depending on the number of
questions from the media we hope and
expect to leave time for your questions
as well. And now Ii'm pleased to introduce
the 20th president of Princeton University
and a former physics major at this
University, Christopher Eisgruber. Chris?
CHRISTOPHER L. EISGRUBER: Thank you Dan.
It's my pleasure to be able to welcome all of you
to this press conference this afternoon.
Joining me here on stage is the chair
of the physics department, Professor
Lyman Page, and of course the man of the
hour, 2016 Nobel laureate in physics
Professor Duncan Haldane.
Professor Haldane's biography is now
known to the world so I will recite the
details only briefly so that we can
spend as much time as possible hearing
from him.
Duncan Haldane is the Eugene Higgins
Professor of Physics at Princeton
University, where he has been a member of
our faculty since 1990. In London Duncan
studied physics at the University of
Cambridge, where he received his B.A. with
first class honours in 1973 and his
doctorate in 1978, but he told me as we
were waiting just before this conference
that he spent the last two years of
those doctoral studies here at Princeton
with his adviser Philip Anderson,
himself a laureate who is with us here
in the audience today. From 1977 to 1981
he was a physicist at the Institut Laue-Langevin
in Grenoble, France. He then became
an assistant professor at the University
of Southern California in 1981, where he
remained on the faculty until
1987. Duncan also served as a member of
the technical staff at ATT Bell
Laboratories in Murray Hill from 1985 to
1988 and during that time luckily for us
once again spent some time at Princeton
as well. Following his stint as professor at the
University of California-San Diego,
Duncan joined the faculty at Princeton
where he has been ever since.
Duncan specializes in the field known
as condensed matter physics.
His research has focused on the use of
advanced mathematical methods to study
unusual states of matter such as
superconductors, superfluids or thin
magnetic films.
Despite the fact that as Dan accurately
said I do have an undergraduate degree
from this distinguished Department of
Physics,
I am utterly unqualified to explain
Professor Haldane's work.
I'm going to leave that to him, but I
will remind you all of what was said in
this morning's press release. Along with
David J Thouless of the University of
Washington in Seattle and J. Michael
Kosterlitz of Brown University
co-winners of this year's Nobel Prize in
Physics Duncan has used topological
concepts to explain the properties of
chains of small magnets found in some
materials
his work has important implications for
the understanding of new types of
materials with the potential to
influence future generations of
electronics superconductors and quantum
computers Duncan has been widely
recognized for his path breaking
discoveries and condensed matter physics
he held an Alfred P sloan Foundation
fellowship from 1984 288 and was awarded
the Oliver e Buckley condensed matter
physics prize from the American Physical
Society in 1993 is a fellow of the
American Academy of Arts and Sciences
American Association for the Advancement
of science the royal society of london
and the institute of physics in the
united kingdom
he was also named by the institute for
scientific information in 2004 as one of
the 230 most highly cited authors and
physics as i said i will let professor
whole day and tell us more about the
scientific details of his work but i did
want to conclude by adding a personal
reflection as a former student of
physics myself at Princeton one of my
strongest memories of my undergraduate
years here was the day in 1981 Val bitch
won the nobel prize in physics it was a
wonderful moment for the Department for
the University a celebration of the
truly groundbreaking work that goes on
here and as an undergraduate I felt
privileged simply to have a chance to
watch the excitement from the sidelines
when I was up late at night struggling
through difficult problem sets in fine
library i would occasionally seek
inspiration by walking through the halls
of the physics building in gazing at the
portraits of the many Nobel laureates
who had studied in the department or
served on it
faculty i am delighted today to see this
marvelous tradition extended as
Professor Duncan holding becomes the
newest addition to this extraordinary
departments all of Fame
let me now ask professor page to say a
few words after
let me now as Professor page to say a
few words and then we'll hear from this
year
florian I thank you I'll be I'll be
brief I look this is this is a very
special award for us in a department of
unusually creative Peter Duncan stands
out in the in the broader theoretical
community a physicist is known for his
extraordinarily deep insights these are
quotes from letters I've gotten over the
years and mathematical elegance and
personality will see Duncan is
light-hearted and funny she laughs a lot
he has an ironic sense of humor
sometimes shares at faculty meetings
tries hard to feign administrative and
confidence but in the end he always
comes through to helping support his
colleagues and friends he's absolutely
wonderful colleague Duncan is a reminder
of the importance of environments and
communities like Princeton where the
pursuit of knowledge of the forefront
science can flourish his exotic ideas
came from is purely intellectual pursuit
going back some 30 years and they've
been realized in experiments on matter
your absolute zero temperature are sense
and apartment that this is just the
beginning of a new era my colleagues and
department and around the world in both
theory and experiment are pursuing new
knowledge rooted in in Duncan's
pioneering research in this field
broadly condensed matter physics but
also in evolving to encompass atomic
physics is vibrant and exciting with
discoveries reported at Princeton with
remarkable regularity we all we all look
forward to seeing what this work leads
to there's more great science to come
and we all are just deaded and so
thankful for all you've done
thank you
only 16 Nobel laureate not gonna hold
you're very gratified to have played a
part with Michael laureates in coming up
with new ways of thinking and condensed
matter physics that you really have
changed since I was a graduate student
there's a completely new focus on on the
quantum on quantum mechanics in a way
that we didn't understand before and I
would actually also like to say that I
was really guided in all this by the
tremendous training and mentorship i had
from my advice Phil Anderson it really
inspired me even with his undergraduate
lectures at Cambridge my last year that
got me so excited about condensed matter
physics that I had two opportunities
that Cambridge want to work with phil
and want to go into string theory which
was about 10 years before its time
luckily i chose the right
what I say that of course technically
it's kind of difficult to explain what
this prices is really for but what it
really is that before we didn't we
across New the equations of quantum
mechanics and we could write down
shredding equations and solve
model problems and the but we really
didn't have a proper appreciation of all
the kind of things that require
mechanics can do just knowing the
equations doesn't tell you what what
potential solutions are those equations
are and that's really i think the new
way of looking at things that's been
that i was privileged to to to
contribute to a David palace also and
Michael slits was more a classical
physics but actually the costly Dallas
ideas were also incredibly influential
in the quantum mechanics of lower
dimensional system so i worked my way up
from starting with zero dimensional
systems with my advisor phil anderson
and my thesis work then I somehow work
my way around too one dimensional
systems chains of atoms or spins in
which i was fortunate to realize that
but consider the conventional wisdom
about how these things behave well
actually put while plausible with in
fact completely incorrect we looked at
in detail and no one it really check the
details out beforehand and this gave
rise to some some thing which turns out
to have been the first of this new class
of topological topological matter which
is a kind of interesting states of
matter where the boundaries of this
matter
this matter is topologically different
from regular matter which means it can't
get continuously changed from
topological the non-trivial too trivial
and that leads right to give rise to
kind of new degrees of unexpected
degrees of freedom on the surface of
these materials and
this has been a theme this in fact and
then we worked our way up from the
one-dimensional case later to the
two-dimensional case layers of material
within a graphene like structure and i
was fortunate enough to realize again
that through actually just working on a
toy model problem for some other reasons
but you could achieve what was called
the quantum Hall effect without applying
huge magnetic fields which made it a
more practical thing just you could
achieve this just from crystal
structures with a particular kind of
broken symmetry and and from that little
toy model it it went on for a while as a
toy model and later on step up to three
dimensions happened this happened in
$YEAR in philadelphia nearby here with
Charles Canaan and gene millie whoo-hoo
took two copies of a toy model that I
found very useful in in in the
two-dimensional case the graphing like
model and stuck them together and found
that when he glued fluid mirror images
of the thing together it did something
even more interesting which allowed
extensions of three dimensions and all
this kind of theoretical work went on
but after that after was realized that
real materials crystals that you could
find in that you could make here Frank
so such as the barber is now making all
the time to actually exhibit these
topological things and they had these
unusual surface properties that have
been sitting in front of people's eyes
for 30-40 years and no one had noticed
it suddenly this became a huge
revolution and it actually fed back
through the creation of new of actual
materials that behave this way is fed
back even my toy model my toy model from
the ladies has now been was now made
consequences knowing how to how to
manipulate matter and the surprising
thing about this is all the implications
I believe our that
the future a new way of looking at what
quantum mechanics can do and now there's
a huge amount of input from what's now
called quantum information theory which
is really different ways of looking at
all problems and we're really
topological materials at least have been
proposed as one of the routes to the the
the quantum computer which is the dream
so far the unrealized dream but that a
lot of people are working on but I can
see now that this this whole field has
has has burgeoned and this spread is
more more kind of this new way of
thinking has led to new discoveries and
it's quite whatever the the the future
will bring I think it's a very which
field of quantum engineering point of
information technology and that's matter
all coming together and and we've gone a
long way from the way physics condensed
matter physics was when i started
packing
ok
open questions to the media first but
i'm going to start with one that came in
from your hometown london from the
evening standard tucking your day
started with a call from Sweden and four
thirty in the morning but at eleven
o'clock this morning you were in the
classroom teaching graduate students
regularly scheduled class and Matt wats
from the evening standard reported their
wants to know why was it so important
for you to teach class today and if
you're teaching just as important as
your research
what's the matter and matter of you know
Judy your pride to go back in and do one
job and in fact i think it's i think the
lesson should be there all the the grad
these are the classes of of incoming
graduate students and I think all these
graduate students who come in have some
they they have hopes and I think any one
of them could discover something
tremendous and you and get a Nobel Prize
for that matter because in fact it's not
that you you don't get up at the
beginning of the day and say I'm going
to discover something great today you're
doing whatever you're doing and you
happen to chance on something through
some other route and you have to have of
course the the insight to see that what
you found something interesting and and
worth exploring more but i think most
most discoveries end up being made for
reasons completely unrelated to be there
accidental in some way like you were
looking at some problem some other
reason and you found that so in that
sense it's and so I think we ought to
inspiring i think it's a good of it is a
good model role model for the students
right thank you
ok questions from the media who are here
slicing they went up felt so is it
identify yourself i'm phillip current
from the Princeton back at local paper
so does this validate you or do you feel
like you're better at you what you'd now
that doesn't validate your work and in
your life's work and you get a raise for
it as well I guess
what we're happy together
I think of my work my life's work was
validated whether or not whether or not
i got such a prize and I was this I was
very happy that I've actually been
fortunate enough to be able to to make
such contributions to this it's this
field and I don't think you'll need the
prize to validate was working when
doesn't spend the time worrying about if
you're going to get a prize
other questions from the media hora I do
have one of the better your question or
identifiers so I cannot be physics
yeah i just want to follow up on your
question now we understand why you want
to teach it to eleven o'clock i want to
know what the student did when you
showed up but well they clap for that
matter
here's a question from Colin Fernandez
he's a science environment correspondent
for The Daily Mail in the UK and he
wonders does the award of the Nobel
Prize for Physics 23 british-born
scientists now living in in America show
that Britain has suffered a brain drain
and Sciences the USA he also wants to
know how you're going to spend the
$MONEY prize my goodness
I'm gonna give a lot of it to be Rs
but yeah the brain drain when i finished
my work I didn't consciously have my
brain drain here but some sense the
opportunity and a lot of that time the
exciting work was going on in the states
and i think at that time with some kind
of policy in Britain perhaps i'm not
sure the mission factor was in power
then but there was some attempt by the
funding agencies to to stress usefulness
of work as opposed to I guess the
National Science Foundation has always
its inspiration based studies or studies
based on the what we call it looking
looking for something interesting you
can't get up and running and say I'm
going to discover something extremely
useful usually something extremely
useful is actually discovered that
completely other reason than it turns
out to be useful so I think partly with
a kind of some kind of politics written
about right
ok if you have any further questions for
the media are all continue to call on
you but why don't we open it up to the
broader audience who has questions for
Duncan our physics laureate yeah your
mic runners ready to bring it bring a
bike too
go back to the well from the reporters
in in Britain also a common friend is
from The Daily Mail wanted to know what
applications could your research bring
ok with you later potentially the one of
the things of these interesting states
on the edge especially on these kind of
flat refereeing like systems is that the
electrical currents go one way only in
one direction and in fact one can do
this with light them analogues of this
in photonics which is the emotion of
light and it's a bit like having the
difference between a crowd of people
moving through each other in opposite
directions on the street with no rules
of the road and now this gives you this
system gives you're not just a rule in
the road of the road where the people
going forward on the left and the people
back with on the right or whichever way
it is in the two countries but in fact
the the two edges are not just the i did
buy a barrier in the middle there kind
of its like 22 size of a freeway that
are completely split by a long distance
so this allows a better flow of the
information without being hindered by
sharp turns in the road which would
could cause you to bounce backwards and
they were under the wrong side and at
least in in this has been one of the
visions that that might come out of such
things but really i think that the main
message is that we're going to find all
kinds of great things that that applying
these new quantum mechanical principles
to matter will allow us to do and we
don't really know what decide the
quantum computer is of course the the
the holy grail of this field but whether
it happened or not we'll find out but
there's a lot of money being put into it
people around the world
ok any other questions from your
ancestor
away from the microphone for just a
moment
kristali physics Duncan I was wondering
what experimental work did you find was
particularly compelling for you in the
area of topological phases of matter
hmm i suppose the only real experimental
work that motivated me with the
discovery by Dan tsui & holster mama and
the other 100 * like they discovered the
something quickly into the quantum Hall
effect now called the integer quantum
Hall effect was discovered by vine clip
by vocalist singing in in 1981 and it
was initially a big mystery it's now our
has a topological component to it and
quite soon after people had understood
it and decided okay they understood it
completely this new effect called the
fractional quantum Hall effect was
discovered by server gossard and three
and that was something that no theorists
we understand it was so that I was a
completely out of the blue experimental
challenge and it took a year or two for
I guess Bob laughing who got a Nobel
Prize for his discovery kind of charged
on the right on the right solution what
turns out to be in the right explanation
so the the three experimental is
completely down founded dumbfounded the
theorists in 1982-83 with this discovery
and that got us thinking trying to find
ways to explain this
I think in the topological filled in
some senses of theorists roof who
provided the guidance for the
experimental thoughtful now so in fact
they're desperately hoping they will
find the fractional equivalent of
topological insulators before the
experimentalist find it because we were
deeply rooted in our pride that such an
unexpected .
really decided we understood everything
completely further questions
this man is over here my phones coming
your way so I'm what projects are you
currently working on
well our challenge i'm interested in in
back back to this all problem of the
fractional quantum Hall effect and i'm
at I've turning my attention a little
bit from apology to quantum topology to
quantum geometry and their lung in
mathematics there with a famous gasps
Bonnie theorem where gas made an
exceptional completely remarkable
discovery that you could relate apology
to the geometry and so I'm trying to go
backwards and lifted look at quantum
effects in the geometry of assistance
yes back Center microphone coming
fine you're right
hey professor how then are there any yet
on conducted experiments you could
imagine that might be really helpful if
money weren't an object and resources
were unlimited kind of experiments that
condensed matter was actually all these
kinds of experiments that the dramatic
amount of money nothing but that they
help help
good idea
well if I offhand I can't tell you which
one night to do right but in fact the i
don't we need lots of there's lots of
him amazing stuff going on with cold
atoms and things were these are kind of
was small
these are not giant experiment we don't
need to build huge expert we do need to
have things like synchrotron light we
need a lot of facilities for shining
various kinds of radiation of the
kindest I hate her son does to to
illuminate these systems with intensity
lightened and see how they behave so we
need user facilities but we don't need
kind of giant LH LH ctypes or in fact or
in fact this as gravitational radiation
needs all right I i have a more
biographical question damn could you say
something about what attracted you to to
physics when you were young was it
something you always felt interested or
was there a teacher who made a huge
difference to well I guess my last one
year school there was an extremely good
chemistry teacher so I could have gone
into chemistry but the last year was the
kind of the physics teacher with was
with quite inspiring and then I didn't
know what I was actually get cambridge
one could one wasn't
as some other English universities
you're tied down to what you said you
wanted to do when you came in but at
least it was sciences but they didn't
have to decide which kind of science and
i found well actually after a few
experiences in chemistry or biology lab
I decided I should not let myself there
any kind of nasty chemicals or
radioactive after having a few spills on
myself I decided I was gonna but
actually i think all the things that
probably due to inspirational teachers
such as Phil Anderson think the quality
of of especially higher-level lectures
is one of the things that really
determines what you're going to go into
you have to show it i think that the
teacher mentor thing is crucial be one
or two more questions anybody hearing
and seeing on this will conclude our
news conference I'd like to thank
everyone for coming today everyone for
tuning in from afar and thanks to all
those who made this so this conference
possible and i think there in about five
minutes or so upstairs in the atrium we
will have a reception for Duncan and we
hope to see all of you up there please
move in an efficient quantum fashion and
let's have one last round of apply